was the arc before that then right
before that uh i feel like it was it was
mainly like a lot of people were hoping
and chris was it seemed was getting
better and that was generally calmed
down a lot and
wasn't doing as many questionable things
is that correct than saying yeah
definitely um
right before this happened there was a
certain book published
on amazon uh comparing andy warhol to
chris chan
and um
why
because apparently there was a there was
a legit argument for that all right
there was some
some interesting comparisons there uh i
actually had i was in contact with the
author before was published and and he
gave me a like a advanced copy so it
seemed pretty good i guess yeah and you
were right through it oh i guess it was
good i didn't read too much of it though
yeah didn't have much time but chris
apparently did have enough time they
bought that themselves and they were
reading through it and uh
yeah they were enjoying it actually
that's what's weird is that chris
participates and consumes all the stuff
about themselves right i mean in a sense
there's like kind of a
kind of coolness to being compared to
someone like andy warhol right like as
much as like some weird [ __ ] andy warhol
has done in his life he's also like an
artist yeah so like i think to chris
would be like oh cool someone says i'm
like andy wahl that's kind of that's
kind of it
what's what's uh most sad about this
whole story is that at any point during
chris's earlier life could have been
salvaged if their parents just took away
the [ __ ] internet right yeah take
away the ps5 something just do something
like a complete lack of parenting in
many ways yes yeah why why how on earth
was chris posting all this stuff online
you know and the parents had absolutely
zero knowledge how did that happen and
if they did have knowledge why the [ __ ]
didn't they stop any of this well maybe
because they're old age right it could
be maybe they're like a generation gap
they didn't understand the impact of i
don't think they understood the idea i
just feel like everyone in their life
has just failed chris yeah and it just
feels like now chris is now just a part
of that cycle as well yeah and well it's
what happens when your parents fail you
and you take
you know you often pick up you know i'm
sure we've all done it or you've picked
up aspects of your parents that you're
like oh god i wish i didn't pick that up
yeah little things you know but normally
with most people it's little quirks you
know it's like like all like you know
things you say yeah yeah it's small
behavior not you know not life
destroying yeah habits most of the time
exactly um
yeah scary
it is a chilling tale about
uh parenting i feel most most the time
where do you think it all went wrong or
where do you think uh christmas failed
the most was it and how much blame do
you put on chris
that's tricky yeah
a lot of the blame goes to the parents
at the very beginning they uh encouraged
chris to um to see the world as against
chris you know because because chris had
autism and they were treated differently
because chris had autism and any action
that chris did
could be excused because chris had
autism right so so kind of uh so so
chris was raised with this understanding
that the world was bullying chris all
the time um
that's something you should teach to
your kid so so chris was given the
mindset of i'm always the victim but
also i can be excused for my actions
yeah chris um
because they're parenting was so bad
chris was mostly raised by television by
uh cartoons by
james anime games right by pornography
as well right uh chris learned most of
most of the outside world from those
sources and um
chris would often uh say things that
would be like cliche lines in a in a tv
show
like um it takes a real man to to admit
his mistakes he would say that and
thinking that that would solve the
problem sounds cool in a tv show yeah
not so much in reality and and they were
infamously and they would infamously in
in their videos we do the the claw of
fail as as they say like like this
threatening gesture right right like a
cartoon villain yeah oh like
fam yeah like that
and always take off their glasses for a
dramatic effect right right
just feels like a lot of that is also
motivated by uh trying to have sex as
well
which is also caused by the media that
chris consumed like as this amazing goal
that that one must achieve uh chris once
stated in the video that that some of
the
like some of the life goals were um
or driving to ohio which chris completed
playing the lottery which chris
completed and the virgin breaker was
still not completed yet so
chris was aiming to uh
take that off this felt like the
monkey's palm of wishing
chris got the wish complete but yeah but
at what cost
everything before before her mother
did she ever lose her virginity yes
really okay really a prostitute oh
that's right that's right i remember
this the prostitute arc of course of
course i remember that the very
of course
the oldest profession in the world
obviously i i feel so bad for the
prostitute
it is it is a
again you you you present a scenario
and you pick the worst worst choice it's
like going through heavy rain pressing
nothing you know what i mean
it's literally the worst outcome and the
worst input in an rpg or something it's
you can't it's favorable just how many
bad decisions were made back to back to
back to back
and still
chris always found a way to get a
[ __ ] internet access yeah and it just
sucks right because you know they they
were given the choice and they always
picked the wrong choice and it sucks
because no one was there to lead them in
the right direction right like because
the trolls are the only ones you can
control
and of course gonna lead them down the
wrong direction if it feels like in this
in a in a way that chris was raised by
trolls you know yeah
about people being raised by wolves and
whatever
honestly because some of this stuff
sounds feral you know
it does almost sound like that level of
just a case study where you have a child
that's just raised by wolves except just
replace the wall living in the mountains
we replace the walls with uh the like
the most like the lowest internet trolls
you can think of and this is this is
what you get yeah very unfortunate as
well that i think the time around chris
was raised was uh definitely like the
whole like american pie era of films
where sex was like the goal
if you were a young boy
16 it was like everything was about even
when i was growing up i'm sure you guys
felt the same about everything in media
was like
get laid get like oh my god you're gonna
lose your virginity tonight at the prom
you know that's how it was you know um
and as the movies would say it's always
at the third date yeah so chris always
specified that no sex before the third
day yeah
but i imagine if it came up in the
conversation i'm sure chris would have
been uh delighted uh
um yeah yeah to to add on the uh being
raised by by trolls thing chris was
actually given lots of reasonable advice
i guess by the trolls during that era of
2009 2010 like clean up your room and
stop and get a job and get at least a
part-time job in walmart for example and
um trolls were trying to make chris
realize that sonichu could never make
them money because it was an
amalgamation of pokemon and
you can file that ip so yeah
they wanted chris to give up on that
fantasy and you know be uh be more
productive in society which chris
did not do but at this point chris had
never been made to
have to do anything that they didn't
like chris had always just doing
whatever they wanted to do right just
want to play games all day chris will
play games all day so it's kind of i
think it's hard when you've gotten to
the age of
20 25 yeah and then you're suddenly told
hey don't play video games anymore don't
don't do these things online
yeah start working at nine to five
that's never gonna happen yeah you know
and and if
the person is never forced to do that
you know by parents or an external force
of course it's not gonna happen i only
worked in mcdonald's because my parents
told me it was a good idea and i wanted
money yeah that's all i wouldn't have
done it
but what's so weird is that this those
same trolls who were telling chris to
you know get a job and clean his room
with the same trolls who were like hey
you should shove your medal yeah